I'll tell you what happened to me papa
today man whatever last day of shooting
before let you know to month of hiatus I
have emotional teen scene with Jenna and
Oliver crying and it's a the notes
time's running out you could feel the
tension in the room we got to get this
you know you can hear it right they go
action Oliver says you know think a
Terry and Jana and Elton my [ __ ]
phone goes off oh that's a ringtone yeah
and this lady's calling me you never
have your ringer I know but what the
[ __ ] you calling me for doing let's see
make sure that you're here on time Lyla
and all of a sudden happen oh my god
[ __ ] like it was one of those and I'm
frantically trying out you know man
cuz if I do this I talk to her so I'm
trying to turn off the [ __ ] thing
right and everyone's all [ __ ] pissed
off bro how come your phones on oh yeah
I love how that's my fault because I
have to play my games between takes
ah that makes completely Deb wait there
we go sound yeah with sound so that does
that make sense to you David yes cuz I
was wrong for asking that question
see and that's why that's why I can
you're waiting you're coming back the
third time you're winning and that's
what you're gonna make it thank you
because you're yes man and I like it yes
are these other cowards in this room
right like this spineless white nothing
right this jelly this translucent white
piece of [ __ ] right he's not a yes man
he is getting there
yeah she's definitely not I said no man
and this new fat guy in back of me I
have no idea
mysterious it's mysterious where's Bryce
yeah where is my friend all my brother's
doing it to his right now - uh-huh
is he a traitor even if he goes to your
brothers podcast no because it's family
oh nice and I'm good - I would - good -
my family that's morals it is right okay
yeah so what you've been doing this last
year
honestly I just been losing weight
that's like woulda what do you been
doing though to lose weight walking
that's it yeah actually right I'm not
even looking really good for weight loss
baby and it doesn't cuz like you like
typically what I used to do is I used to
think that I am somebody that I'm not
so I I would go into the gym and I look
at Bart and I'm like I'm Bart I would
hit these weights yeah I would end up in
the hospital yeah I decided to just tone
it down the opposite way and just start
walking
yeah and so I just walked by three four
miles a day really yeah every day so you
wake up you go I'm gonna do I'm gonna
walk three miles oh where does one go
it's whenever there's not to be in the
morning just well whenever during the
day you know me all right well you
decide to do it in the hood in the
neighborhood yeah you have a route yeah
have a rap all right dawg
that's all be playing what's going why
are we getting aggressive where'd you go
yeah yeah I just want to know your
[ __ ] routine bro it's the same
routine I wake up and then sometimes I
do in the morning if not if I don't get
it done in the morning I do it at night
yeah and then I'm just that creepy guy
in the neighborhood I like those like
know the like old Asian couples they I
used to work at the Abercrombie in the
Glendale Galleria and we would close the
shops everything would be closed you'd
see like Asian couples just walking
doing their cardio in the mall that's me
that is me but they're faster than I am
I'm substantially slower than them but
you know why
you look different bet you 50 pounds
what can I say something and I want to
say something yeah okay you look more
handsome thank you
but you you lost a little bit of the
funny look it's true yeah like before
when I used to look at you you just
laughs I just cackle like a hyena you
know me because you look so weird and
funny right
like when I you know people see me they
cackle like hyenas nah yeah they do is
I'm pudgy and I'm weird looking at you
know you think you're I move I move
weird you know I mean that's true yeah
like I do this
they Ryan people I do that I make noises
right and people love it right but now
you know you look handsome now
you know you're more now in the category
of John Cho Steven Yeun then jeongmi you
know there's nothing that ken Jeong can
do to make himself look sexy is his
frame is what you have to do nothing the
his bones are [ __ ] he's a tiny guy
though he's small frail bony and he
physically assaulted me one time in a
real physical fight would you say I
would crush his [ __ ] cheekbones in
well you guys actually got into a fight
before yeah over what I found a lost our
Asian comedians like like that fan big
fan of his some people in this room
aren't but why I'm a big fan of that fan
I didn't know that let me see the
picture behind him same photo do we have
a framed photo dude I like how you
pointed at the picture but you chose to
block it with your head best friends
forever do you know
[Music]